Asexuality is an extremely misunderstood sexual identity.
Sexual intimacy is important for many of us.
Because most of society deems sexual attraction important, asexuals are often ostracized and even
pitied for their sexual orientation.
Asexual people often feel out of place because of the lack of knowledge concerning asexuality. Well, we've got some news for you.
Asexual people don't need your pity. They need your understanding.
Confused about what it means to be asexual?  Psych2Go has a list of the basics that the ace community would like you to know.
What is asexuality?
Asexuality is broadly defined as a lack of sexual attraction.
People who identify as asexual or ace are not typically sexually attracted to anyone.
According to current statistics,
1% of the North American population
identifies as asexual, though many sexual psychology experts believe this number is higher.
Asexuality is a sexual orientation.
Asexuality is a sexual orientation that falls in line with heterosexuality, or bisexuality, or homosexuality.
Asexuality can sometimes work in tandem with another orientation.
An individual can identify as asexual but can be romantically attracted to other people
Some asexuals don't date.  Some asexual people are a romantic.
They do not feel romantic attraction to people and so they don't feel the need to seek dates or relationships.
Some asexuals do date.
Asexuality is not a fear of intimacy. Many asexual people do have romantic attractions to other people and actively seek relationships.
Asexual people can seek connections with other people of the opposite sex: heteroromantic, or people of the same or either sex:
homoromantic and biromantic,
respectively.
Asexuality is not celibacy.
Celibacy is a decision that an individual makes. It is the choice to refrain from sexual conduct.
Asexuality is an orientation, an attitude and feeling towards sexuality.
Asexuality is not a disorder. There is nothing wrong with being asexual.
Asexuality is not something that needs to be fixed. Many people confuse
asexuality with disorders like sexual aversion disorder or SAD, which is a persistent and fear-based avoidance of sexual contact.
People with SAD often experience distress or panic during sex.
SAD is a mental condition.
Asexual people may feel anxious about societal pressure to be sexually active but, sex itself is not an anxiety.
An asexual person just doesn't view sex as an interest.
Asexuals can enjoy sexual intimacy.
Asexuality is a spectrum and not everyone lies on the same notch on the scale.
There are in fact asexuals who enjoy sexual experiences.
While many don't feel the need to, some asexual people do masturbate and explore sexuality on their own.
Others can enjoy sexual intimacy with others while not being sexually attracted to anyone.
Just as with other sexualities,
asexuality is different for every individual.
We hope you enjoyed this video!
Do you identify as ace and have something you'd like to share with the site to go community? Tell us in the comments section below!
Would you like to know more about asexuality and asexual visibility?
Visit the Asexual Visibility and Education Network (AVEN) at asexuality.org.
Also, be sure to subscribe to our channel for more helpful tips and share this video with others. With your help,
we can reach more people to explore intriguing topics like this. Thanks for watching. :)